car le vice président de l'association
des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
bonjour merci encore une fois d'être
avec nous en ce vendredi ben écoutez je
m'en voudrais de ne pas pour poser comme
première question qu'est ce que vous
pensez du plan de deux pistes dépistage
qui était proposée aujourd'hui par le
docteur arruda
vous avez ça c'est le nerf de la guerre
de tester je pense que tout le monde est
conscient et au courant de ça depuis
longtemps
la question c'est que c'est pas vraiment
un nouveau plan c'est juste le fait
qu'il faut augmenter notre capacité de
faire des tests
ce qu'on essaie de faire au québec
depuis je vous dirais longtemps donc là
on fait à peu près signé sept mille
tests par jo il ya eu toutes sortes de
problèmes d'approvisionnement au niveau
des tests au niveau de la difficulté de
faire des tests pour toutes sortes de
raisons on a et on a fait des tests un
petit peu de façon aléatoire ça a été
énormément travail de la part de
beaucoup de gens mais on était limité
dans notre capacité
alors là on veut des confiné on est
obligé d'avoir une capacité accrue en
termes de tests pour pouvoir suivre des
éclosions potentiel pour pouvoir suivre
l'épidémiologie potentiel surtout au
niveau des écoles et au niveau par
exemple des industries n'a imaginé vaut
une usine où vous allez avoir trois
quatre employés malades et vous voulez
savoir combien sont réellement malade
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'actuellement
on n'a pas l'image actuelle
d'épidémiologie dans l'appareil parce
que quand on annonce et ça fait
longtemps qu'on le répète quand on
annonce le nombre de tests de nouveaux
cas positifs par jour c'est le nouveau
câble parmi les gens contestent c'est à
dire des populations très ciblé les
patients hospitalisés les gens dans les
chsct
les travailleurs de la santé mais on n'a
pas le nombre de gens malades dans la
population générale et on sait parce que
des fois on a des patients hospitalisés
qui nous disent clairement qu'il ya
trois quatre cinq six personnes autour
d'eux qu'ils sont malades
on les a pas testé ces gens là alors ce
que ça dit sadi qui a probablement
peut-être il ya des études qui montrent
est ce que c'est une personne qui est
testé sur 12 une personne sur 15 une sur
vingt
ça peut varier selon les études mais
c'est probablement dans cette dans cet
ordre de grandeur
on a appris aujourd'hui de la plume de
mon collègue thomas germain qui a des
travailleurs entre le ministère de la
santé aurait étudié autorisé en dernier
cours il faut le dire des travailleurs
de la santé à se rendre en institution
ch et celle des autres hôpitaux avant la
fin de leur période d'isolement ayant
même le virus c'est assez étonnant ce
même en dernier recours nash et qu'on
manque de travailleurs mais qu'est ce
que vous pensez de sa maîtresse est
vraiment en dernier recours c'est même
un petit peu dangereux pense qu'on en a
des gens qui sont potentiellement
infectieux ces gens là d'abord doit se
déplacer de leur domicile vers leur
endroit de travail donc comment est ce
qu'ils vont faire
est-ce qu'ils vont porter un masque
continuellement et dont il ya plusieurs
question qu'on peut se poser par rapport
à ça je pense que aussi une des
questions qu'on peut se poser c'est que
dans les chsct il y avait toute une
capacité de jeunes travailleurs qui
étaient disponibles et qui aurait
probablement dû être mobilisés
relativement rapidement vous savez on a
beaucoup d'étudiants en médecine au
québec y en a quatre mille il ya
probablement des dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants ou d'étudiants en sciences
infirmières il ya aussi beaucoup
d'étudiants dans les sciences de la
santé
donc il ya facilement 30 40 mille jeunes
relativement bonne santé qui ont très
peu de risque de faire des complications
et qui étaient disponibles et qui
viennent des domaines de la santé où ça
aurait été en plus de ça un
apprentissage humain et en plus de
l'aspect scientifique d'aller danser ch
et celle des messages envoyés à envoyer
des gens qui sont malades en laisse et
lâcher saleté c'est un peu dangereux
parce que ces gens là est ce qu'ils vont
retourner après dans d'autres milieux de
la santé oms n'a pas cloisonné où vit en
paix alors imaginez vous qu'on a des
gens qui travaillent dans des hôpitaux
de soins aigus par exemple une urgence
on les a pris on les envoie dans l'iss
et à celle des on leur dit vous êtes
malade on est vraiment mal pris vous
allez continuer travailler et à ce
moment là on va aller en tirs après ça
vous allez revenir dans votre
environnement
alors on sait pas trop comment ce
truc-là gérer mais c'est sûr que c'était
un risque et un peu inquiétant il faut
lire ces gens là doivent aussi aller de
chez eux au ch et celle des camps est ce
qu'ils font ça questions du public
il ya une question qui nous est posée
royaume uni en france les enfants sont
hospitalisés avec des symptômes
inflammatoires grave il part de la
maladie de kawasaki
est ce qu'on doit craindre ça pour les
enfants ici également ceux qui
développent la par exemple de
l'inflammation des orteils on a vu des
photos de ça cette semaine l'a été c'est
très peu
cible mais c'est quand même des quatre r
vous savez en médecine dans la tendance
à apporter ce qui est inhabituel ce qui
est plutôt rare dont il ya une espèce de
bié probablement dans son rapport alors
oui ça existe
oui le syndrome de camatte kawasaki a
été remportée en grande bretagne il ya
en france des gens qui ont rapporté des
choses similaires et une certaine des
syndromes inflammatoires du tube
digestif mais c'est l'exception plutôt
que la règle pour l'immense majorité du
temps les enfants surtout ceux en bas de
10 ans très peu de problèmes avec la
comique 19 et les adolescents c'est très
rare aussi way d'avoir problème il nous
reste et nous reste deux caves à ce très
peu de temps je m'excuse de vous
interrompre une autre question en
terminant si montréal est la ville qui a
le plus haut taux de contamination est
elle aussi la ville qui a le plus grand
nombre de personnes immunisées peut-être
peut-on utiliser cette logique ou pas ça
oui tout à fait en effet l'un va avec
l'autre un moment donné quand je vous
dis si pour chaque test positif vous en
avez vous en avez à peu près une
quinzaine qui sont pas testés mais qui
ont quand même fait des maladies c'est
qu'il doit avoir une proportion de la
population qui est plus élevé en termes
d' immunité à montréal qu'à québec et
que certainement dans d'autres régions
du québec
même chez weiss de weiss merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de semaine et on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine au revoir
merci également aux stands soirée